what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest episode of the attack
on titan final season
this episode showed us what happened
during the time skip and after our side
return to paradise island along with
zeke so make sure to stay tuned for this
one
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
titan videos and want to keep them
coming then the best thing to do is
warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on
titan fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos and while
you wait for the next insane episode to
drop
feel free to check out our growing
attack on time playlist where we got
videos about all the titan shifters and
their powers
the acronyms and their powers the time
during the weakest to strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it no manga spoilers
only this anime episode spoilers
obviously so this episode is called
brave volunteers and as i briefly
mentioned a good portion of it is taking
place during the time skip so a
flashback
it's framed with armin holding a
seashell and talking to someone
remember that the c and the seashell in
particular represented
freedom adventure and optimism for both
armin
and aaron they always dreamed of going
outside the walls and seeing all the
stuff armin heard about
from a book of the outside world where
it mentioned a body of salt water so
large that you can never run out of it
you'd have to be crazy inside the walls
to believe such a thing but
aaron and armin did and couldn't wait to
see it one day
when they finally did make it to the sea
and armin picked up that seashell it was
a much more optimistic time
as armin will later tell annie who he's
talking to it was fun back then
meaning before aaron attacked marley in
the flashback air used his attack titan
powers to lift the marley and ships that
were approaching the island they'd take
the ships which were a source of useful
technological information for them
remember they do have to catch up in
regards to technology and specifically
weapon technology so that they won't get
destroyed by the world and particularly
marley
yelena also came zeke's devoted follower
the ldn side had nikola as a hostage to
use against marley but obviously the
marlene leader didn't care he was about
to release fire when yelena shot him and
agreed to speak with hanji
yelena onyankopon and the others are the
volunteers many of them were from
conquered nations that felt helpless and
hopeless against marley's might
until zeke who yelna views as a god gave
them hope of resisting marlene this is a
very interesting twist and it's also
interesting hearing about the
ramifications that the island aldeans
beating the warrior unit and stealing
two of marley's titan powers
had on the rest of the world a lot of
nations unified and rebelled and keep in
mind this was three years ago from the
present day
so the fort slala battle at the
beginning of the season was pretty much
marley wrapping up those conflicts that
popped up due to what happened on
paradise island they didn't immediately
counter-attack the island because
despite having advanced technology and
even advanced aerial technology
a detail which freaked hanji out by the
way they still had their hands full
and ironically the pure titans around
the walls that they created to keep the
island devils in fear and trap them
inside
also discourage them because the idea of
them made land attacks pretty impossible
to carry out before this piece of
information
the fact that the islanders defeated all
the pure titans seemed like a huge
accomplishment
but now it's like oh no what have we
done luckily though yelena and the
others did come to help and so there is
still hope as leona says
what zeke reportedly wants is to free
the eldian people
and they the anti-marlene volunteers
are here to help make sure that happens
obviously a lot of people don't want to
trust zeke
and you can understand where they're
coming from completely the dude as was
mentioned
almost wiped out the survey core and now
they're supposed to trust him it
obviously seems like he's just trying to
get aaron the founding titan power
and that might have been it the end of
zeke's secret plan if aaron didn't step
in by the way if you want to know
exactly what this secret plan entails
i just dropped a video today about it so
you can check it out link in the
description
but i won't go into manga spoilers here
so if you're in anime only
let me know what you suspect zeke's plan
to be and how he plans to carry it out
but anyways zeke's half-brother aaron
mentions that
zeke speaks the truth when he the
founding titan user
came into contact with the royal-blooded
titan dina fritz aka zeke's mom he was
able to control titans he had access to
the valentine's power
for a brief time he kept it to himself
because he didn't want them to turn
historia into a titan
so he could use the powers but now he's
willing to say that zeke's right
and of course if anyone empathizes with
the idea of freeing ldns it's aaron
aaron's stand combined with the fact
that they didn't really have another
option due to marlene technology
being way more advanced leads to the
ldns working with the anti-marley and
volunteers
and as armin said this was a fun time
because yes
they were hated by many people but there
were people who were on their side
like yelena and onyankopun even nicolo
changed he once wanted to die rather
than work with the aldians but after
cooking for sasha that all changed
connie clearly had some competition in
nicolo for sasha's affections because
sasha loves food and as she pointed out
nicolo
was a food genius connie mentioned that
sasha was like a twin to him but nikolo
would always get red-faced around her he
apparently loved her and how much she
loved his cooking and when you're
dealing with a girl
like sasha the weight to her heart is
definitely through her stomach
sasha was as lovable as always during
this flashback
and would randomly take naps get
overjoyed about food and all those other
awesome sasha things
these moments hit all the harder because
we know
she is destined to die in the future
during this time you have these
relationships formed between the two
sides
still though the majority of the
marleyans get arrested because they do
not want to help the islanders
and here we get to see why and how aaron
starts strength away from the others he
knows that their time is running out
zeke only has three years left his time
is quickly running out before amir's
curse takes place
and he dies or passes on his power for
armin and mikasa
the key is time given enough time people
can understand each other and armand and
mikas are a bit too
idealistic for aaron because armin
believes that threatening the world
with wall titans will make them look
like the devils people say they are
armin is hesitant
he wants to wait and solve this
peacefully but as aaron says
they need time that they don't have and
so he's going to buy that time
and if buying that time means attacking
marley making contact with zeke and
activating the rumbling and the colossal
tines in the walls he is down to do it
so by himself he decides to attack
marley
because of this he scares the world and
gets zeke so now they have access to the
rumbling and hopefully people won't
attack them for fear of being wiped out
by the insanely powerful founding titan
looking back now from the present tense
armin wonders if threatening the world
and killing all those people was the
only way
especially since it led to sasha's death
but he admits that he had to do it
especially after aaron attacked had he
not destroyed the port
they would have immediately countered
attacked parodies island he compares
himself to annie who he feels like
probably felt the same way
she didn't want to attack the islanders
but she felt like she had to do it
again attack on titan is so good at
showing all of these different
perspectives
and how no one really knows what the
right choice is
or if they made it we do get to see
people in the present visiting sasha at
her grave
nicolo actually gets terribly beaten up
because his people the marlenes put most
of these people in graves
he's not even bothered by it because he
feels so bad and angry about what
happened to sasha but this
again shows how the islanders are just
as capable of prejudice as the marlenes
who view them all as devils
we get a really touching moment where
nikola offers to cook sasha's family the
food she loved so much
they could show the same prejudice the
guy beating him up did
however her father reaches his hand out
and accepts the offer
we see this glimpse of hope we see how
people can cross racial and cultural
lines
and come together but the reality of the
situation is some people are much more
prejudiced than these guys and if it is
possible for them to change
then how much time are we talking there
is hope but aaron doesn't want to die
waiting for something to happen as
always he'd rather fight and do
everything he can to ensure his people's
safety
you might remember during the first
season aaron deeply regretted trusting
the levi's squad to take out the female
titan because it got them killed i'm
sure this haunts him to this day
and even though armin and the others
want him to place his trust in them
he's afraid that if he leaves it to them
his friends will die like last time
and then we figure out that in the
present things are not quite going as
the jaeger brothers plan
after finally coming together levi
actually is keeping zeke arrested for
all intents and purposes
he's taking him away from aaron into the
titan forest where he could easily cut
him down if he changed into the beast
titan by the way fun fact
here in the anime we do have zeke
mentioning how levi is staring at him
but in the manga he also says that if he
keeps staring at him like that he'll pee
his pants but moving on
similarly pixis and the others have
turned on zeke's followers and it seems
like they'll be imprisoned
finally aaron seems to be in jail too in
the underground where they usually keep
titan shifter prisoners
also gabby and falco are in prison and
you can see why gaby is just gonna keep
getting more hate
even after she killed our precious
potato girl she's not
sad about it she's just furious and
directing all her energy towards hating
aaron
at this point her face reminds me of
azula from avatar after she goes off the
deep end
and let me know what you're thinking now
do you believe
that they should be separating zeke and
aaron and arresting all the people that
helped them advance their technology so
they'd actually have a fighting chance
against marley i must admit for me when
i was first reading this in the manga
this seemed pretty stupid on their end
they are leaving themselves completely
vulnerable to an attack now now that
they finally have the power to keep the
island safe
they have separated the two key
ingredients so they can't use it
i get them not trusting zeke but come on
you could have at least kept them closer
in the case the power is needed but hey
those are just my thoughts
let me know yours we close off this part
with mikasan air and talking to
themselves repeating what they've been
repeating
since they were kids and aaron saved
mikasa from the kidnappers
and then mikasa in turn saved aaron from
a third one
they're saying fight or die win and live
the only way to win is to fight
this is clearly aaron's philosophy and
is keeping him going despite all the
horrors he's had to commit
which include ending the lives of
children while armin might be wishing
and even believing there might be
another way a peaceful way
aaron doesn't resonate with that for him
such a plan
is akin to waiting to get killed and
he'd rather fight for his life in the
lives of his people
then stand by and put the fate of the
world in the hands of his enemies
in the preview we're told kill their
enemies to live
not a soul knows if it's the right
choice that's exactly it
it's easy to argue with aaron and
philosophize about another way
like armin wants to do but no one is
sure that aaron's choice wasn't the
right one
and no one's sure they have a better
plan let me know your thoughts
what would you do right now if you were
from parodies island i also mentioned
that there was a nice moment where sasha
was curious about
why onyan kopon had darker skin because
she'd never
seen anyone of his race before he
replies that the creator thought it
would be more fun to create
all sorts of humans they all exist
because they are wanted and the same
creator
that made him gave a mere titan powers
although he knows that this may seem
silly to some people
he thinks it's great that us humans are
free to think what we want and
onyancopon's view
makes a lot of sense to me if you're
alive you're wanted you're supposed to
be here
don't let anyone tell you otherwise the
world is telling aldians from the island
that they shouldn't exist but aaron
rightfully refuses to accept this view
he wasn't born into this world just to
take himself out of it without a fight
lastly i will mention that it's so funny
when levi speaks with the marlenians on
the ships in the beginning
after he gets insulted called filthy and
is accused of liking pig piss
he later tells another group that
they'll love it on the island as long as
they love pig piss
that made me laugh so much but yeah that
is it for this episode as
always let me know your thoughts on it
if you read the manga did you like the
way this was animated
and if you haven't read the manga what
do you expect to see happening next let
me know
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
titan episode reviews and want to keep
them coming then the best thing to do is
warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on
titan fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos
and while you wait for the next insane
episode to drop you could actually check
out our new
anime virgin podcast where right now
we're actually reliving attack on titan
with someone who's never watched it
before
making him the anime attack on titan
virgin so if that sounds like something
you'd be interested in reliving the
series from the beginning and seeing how
someone who's not an
anime fan actually reacts to it then
i'll put the link in the description or
you could just search up the anime
virgin podcast
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand on top all clans ingrata the
world
acquire respect pate heffa liam thompson
al-jatal
dr kortman johnny boyd draws emperor
otaku spidey life tinel baked buddhist
and tungsten tarkis
and are pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
faun rethu and aura
alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami and
water the red haired raven joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as low as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
epic people right here and you'll even
get access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support work on that way if you prefer
and whichever way you choose to support
us you can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you